now we didn't want to start this channel
out with a video about tardigrades we
wanted to share at least a bit about
some of the other mind-blowing organisms
of the micro cosmos first but we also
knew it wasn't gonna be long before we
got to them we are it must be admitted
to her two great enthusiasts and we've
been excited to watch as a fair number
of people have joined us in that
enthusiasm however of course and we're
not mad about this
the popular narratives about tardigrades
have in their enthusiasm gotten a few
things less than correct and also
skipped over some of the most
interesting facets of this celebrity of
the micro cosmos so tardigrades they're
chubby and they have heads and legs and
butts and they look at first glance
somewhat familiar that's why we
sometimes call them water bears or even
better in our opinion moss piglets
because they are often in the aquatic
environments that cling to mosses but
they are also very unlike macro animals
for one thing they have eight legs for
another thing they are not closely
related to anything else on earth though
taxonomist s-- are still fighting about
this the leading system places
tardigrades inside of a clade called
tak dupatta that includes two groups
there's tardigrades and there's
something called you Arthropoda
and that other clade includes basically
every bug insects arachnids even
crustaceans and trilobites the organism
that branched away from tardigrades
has literally millions of species as its
ancestor but the branch that tardigrades
said on just tardigrades though there
are over a thousand described tardigrade
species and there are likely many times
more than that out there but nonetheless
they do look a lot like bears with their
claws and stumpy four pairs of legs
tardigrades have a right on the edge of
microscopic they range widely in size
from 50 microns long to 1200 microns but
usually they're under 500 microns in
size
tardigrades can be found in three major
aquatic environments the some live in
marine or brackish water others in fresh
waters like ponds lakes and rivers and
then there are the terrestrial habitats
but this isn't exactly what it sounds
like sea tardigrades do live on what we
would consider land but they live in
films of water clinging to plants and
dirt this thin film though nearly
invisible to us can be a tardigrades
whole world but these films can easily
dry up in the daytime which is part of
why tardigrades are so good at surviving
difficult situations which of course we
will be discussing shortly
[Music]
they occupy almost every place on earth
from the Arctic to the Antarctic from
soil to beach sand rivers lakes streams
on mosses lichens algae and plants we
know of a couple of places where we can
almost certainly find them waddling
around in samples we take and we will
make a whole episode about that process
but that's for later
although they are aquatic tardigrades
don't swim they kind of walk in
freshwater they live among vegetation
and mainly feed on the cell contents of
plants and algae by piercing the cells
with the to stylist they have in their
mouths part but some species eat
single-celled organisms or even other
micro animals including rotifers and
also other tardigrades
some species of tardigrades have eyes
besides helping them look super cute
they also boggle the mind because they
aren't eyes to be an eye you have to be
an organ and to be an organ you have to
be composed of tissues that are
themselves composed of cells but each
tardigrade eye is in fact a single
photoreceptive cell that is wild on
their whole body
sometimes containing tens of thousands
of cells they have two cells and those
two cells are their two little eyes
tardigrades are also covered in a kind
of skin or shell called a cuticle
coloration is produced by the
pigmentation of the cuticle and also the
content of the digestive tract gray
bluish yellow brown reddish or brown are
all common colors this cuticle always
stays the same size and so it must be
shed as the tardigrade grows some
species of tardigrades lay their eggs
into this cuticle which expands to hold
them and then when the cuticle is shed
the eggs stay inside giving them an
extra layer of protection from roving
predators if those eggs manage to avoid
being eaten they will hatch into tiny
little tardigrade 'lets that oddly
enough have the same number of cells
that they will always have but their
cells and thus their bodies will grow
larger
tardigrades are marvelously complex for
such tiny animals they have digestive
systems and salivary glands even small
brains the most complex have over 40,000
cells and yes when they are done
extracting nutrients from their food
they have to get rid of it just like the
rest of us of course
tardigrades are best known for their
survival skills many species have the
ability to survive environmental
extremes such as temperatures as low as
negative two hundred and seventy-two
degrees Celsius and as high as a hundred
and fifty degrees Celsius extreme
radiation extreme pressures as high as
six thousand atmospheres NASA sent a
bunch of tardigrades to outer space and
brought them back alive after exposing
the animals to the vacuum of space and
extreme radiation from the Sun a
tardigrade may have a lifespan of a
couple of weeks - more than 100 years a
museum specimen of a dried moss that was
in a herbarium for a hundred and twenty
years yielded active tardigrades when
soaked in water
[Music]
tardigrades are able to survive these
extremely hostile conditions by
undergoing a process known as
cryptobiosis encrypt obey osis the
metabolism of the tardigrades can lower
to less than 0.01 percent of normal and
when conditions get better the
tardigrades simply get back to life
there are actually several kinds of
cryptobiosis in an hydro bios's
tardigrades are dealing with a lack of
water and they curl up into a ball
called a ton to survive being all dried
up a glass like protective sugar
trehalose is synthesized and it replaces
the water in the cells of the
tardigrades this sugar prevents crucial
parts of the cells from getting damaged
during the water loss and it lets
tardigrades survive the dry period an
oxy biosis occurs when there's
insufficient oxygen the body of the
tardigrade swells and become rigid and
turgid there's no movement and the
tardigrade looks dead
this sometimes happens in our prepared
slides so when it happens we simply blow
air into the slide from the side for
around 10 seconds and that is enough to
increase the oxygen concentration and
revive the water bear and there are
other types of cryptobiosis such as cryo
bios's where tardigrades can withstand
extremely low temperatures and Osmo by
OSIS where they can withstand changes in
osmotic pressure
[Music]
one of the misconceptions about
tardigrades is that they are immortal
they are resistant to these extreme
conditions when they are in tonnes state
but otherwise there are actually quite
delicate animals and can be hurt and
killed easily because of their small
size
tardigrades are eaten by some even
bigger single-celled organisms in this
video we managed to record a close
encounter between a tardigrade and a
giant eukaryote we don't even know what
this single-celled organism here is let
us know if you think you can identify it
but it could easily eat the tardigrade
and digest it with this lucky little one
managed to escape and even damaged the
cell of the eukaryote in the process and
in this clip we have a happy tardigrade
waddling on one of the most dangerous
residents of the ponds a brown Hydra
hydras tentacles are armed with
something called numata cysts these are
like tiny harpoons that are fired upon
contact to immobilize the hydras prey
this water bear was either very lucky or
too small to activate the 'no mattis's
sand so got away from a heartbreaking
end
tardigrades are not extremophiles they
do not enjoy living in extreme
conditions they're just good at
surviving them in that way maybe they
are something like us we also sometimes
live through situations we thought would
be impossible to survive but all things
being equal both tardigrades and us just
want a nice place to live plenty of
yummy food and whenever possible to not
be exposed to the vacuum of space we are
so happy that these friends share their
world with us so often just outside of
our notice but successfully chomping
their way
through the micro cosmos for more than
half a billion years and just in case
you wanted to see it again that's good
thank you for coming on this journey
with us through the unseen world that
surrounds us if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes James
check out Jam and germs on Instagram and
if you want to see more from us here at
journey to the micro cosmos I bet
there's a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
we really appreciate everybody's kind
words in the comments it really is just
a joy to make this channel